[Music]
death row toys news submitted by Isaac
Isaac and Xbox your son yeah my son the
toy maker Hasbro now owns a rap label
Death Row Records as a product for
billion dollar acquisition records
that's so [ __ ] weird
this is Hasbro's logo why bitter Linden
this is that's weird
did they acquire it for four billion
dollars or did they buy a conglomerate
that owned it so they bought a
conglomerate that owned death records
it just sounds better when a no way they
bought a one so Hasbro they they had an
acquisition of e1 which is entertainment
one and they had a music division that
they they owned death row records
because they death row records had filed
for bankruptcy back in 2006 after the
whole bunch of lawsuits and the
imprisonment of sug
Suge Knight and so since then the
company has changed hands several times
and it ended up with entertainment one
which was bought for two hundred and
eighty million dollars oh um and then
now Hasbro has acquired that's tight bro
that's holy that's crazy because it
doesn't seem like it fits in their
portfolio at all but if it makes money
it'll fit hey I'm trying all the time
I'm looking forward for that Tupac
play-doh so they were trying to buy
these other companies that were anyone
and then death row happened to be in it
too so Hasbro acquired Entertainment one
because they're saying that they were
looking to expand their family brands
and television
exactly how that found me to go a death
roll ready that was like in there yeah
entertainment one produces Peppa Peppa
Pig okay that's huge EJ matte masks yeah
PJ mess is the PJ masks oh that's such a
funny [ __ ] way holy oh dear yeah I'm
like I've never put the pig in death row
that is the funniest [ __ ]
but they're like what might as well [ __ ]
with it let's go make some action
figures of Tupac yeah but like you could
totally you can always turn it into
something always yeah I want to see them
turn death row into Fagin parody um
characters there's tits in the hood who
listen to that who would love their
action figures yeah they could even have
like play with action figures yeah yeah
I mean I think they have iPads but kids
in the hood can afford uh cuts good good
I know may my up for marketing that I
know because I always wanted to do a
yard silk so I'm like all these these
the kids in my neighborhood are poor
like me so everyone needs toys that it
cheap so I was like all cameras just
slang my toys and nobody bought it cuz
Evan was on welfare and they had money
Wow yeah they could get actual toys yeah
they [ __ ] had that [ __ ] [ __ ] are
my friends over there families around
welfare they had the newest gaming
console always I'm like how are you so
rich
that kind of angers me because were you
on welfare but then you weren't gaming
the system pretty much no my family
wasn't all welfare but I was on welfare
we like it when you have a omean I think
we're on welfare for a little bit and it
was like the most struggling times of my
life as like a single mother and they're
trying to like make a living and trying
to go to school make sure it was hard
but that's why I ended up having to
resort to welfare and I made sure I was
living within my means and I would go to
the Social Security office because I had
to meet with my caseworker and I would
see ladies in there with like [ __ ]
booty bags I'm not a welfare with nails
like the [ __ ] - keep watching my [ __ ]
those women that would go in their
individual faces she means I mean go
picture of you and with the welfare
brilliant a card like here give me your
wallet BC no but yeah like that would
piss me off so much cuz I'm like you so
you're looking [ __ ] like I'm really
struggling here and this is really
helping me so much but your [ __ ]
gaming the system
yeah you just don't want to get a job
how come they got to do that but you did
it yes kids with disability yeah yeah
like like I've heard you're broke your
leg girl I've heard horror stories of
like these women not all a few but the
ones I saw in there was yeah like those
kind of people because it wasn't just
the women either like the guys were
there too so anyway they would go in and
then like they'd be pregnant and I would
see them or I wouldn't see them I would
hear that other people would see them
and like going and smoking and drinking
and I trying to like [ __ ] their baby up
so then they could get more the ocean of
Mexico could only do this [ __ ] here -
wait why do they do it in Mexico well
first I think I'm not welfare but you
know how they like you'll see the little
kid oh no they
gasps yeah like when they're asking for
money like they'll like put the baby to
sleep so the baby looks more poetess eat
though you know so I like when they're
carrying the kid or the baby like it's a
silly old kid or kidnapped I don't know
I don't know the details crazy even like
remember and that's like some yeah
that's some Slumdog Millionaire [ __ ] we
like how they'll like cut off a brain or
maybe our or whatever you are yeah dude
they're people do some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
for money but yeah that's why it's like
people you you know I came from Mexico
and I work on videos let's try those
it's give up what am i recommand and I
was like oh do you have like a whole 20
video video yeah [ __ ] now I'm gonna make
it to one of your videos you are very
good rope this date today she roasted
every single guest I like that I don't
know I was cool with that [ __ ] I don't
look like a home welfare we got the wall
for a look according to
that's racist the rich welfare look like
I got eight kids or why what if I don't
know you're like the queen of welfare
noth-nothing bottom-1
she was the peasant of welfare you kept
digging even harder because you're like
she just looks like it but she's not
okay it's just she literally has a Gucci
purse here and it was just a good
problem she doesn't really have the long
nails gonna help own a tip on it you
want the easiest way well I can help you
okay Sam sorry she's just saying that
someone that looks like you with all
this money and nice things and whatever
should not be on welfare no I agree I
agree that's all it is yeah and it's a
compliment to you actually because
they're trying cuz you don't look like
you're on welfare by doing it by gaming
us today so put that in a tip the Rose
video - yes please don't [ __ ] just
bang me down there because I would have
be spending all that money if I was on
welfare
hell no oh like I would even buy money
I'm like a purse or whatever like I
would try to upgrade my [ __ ] life
when quick question if someone's taking
care like let's say I'm the grandma
writing you're my daughter and you left
me your kids can I charge you out there
yeah I can pay you can pay for like all
to kids know that [ __ ] know their way
that they get more money is by living
right more dependents isn't it like the
more dependents you have no okay so the
grandma if she goes to certain classes
and and this is from like 11 years ago
so things could have changed but if she
goes to classes like childcare classes
and she gets a certain type of
certification that seems from what I
heard isn't like crazy hard to get then
she's able like them the grandma is able
to ask for assistance from the
government to say hey I'm qualified to
get assistance from you because I gave
his kid
like babysitter money he's turning into
like a daycare kind of or a baby sure
yeah you know I'm thinking about it I'm
even thinking me this it's a
certification I think it's even if as
long as you are watching a kid you can
request from the government if it's not
your kid so how did you get off welfare
and why did you want to get it got off
if you're getting free money oh because
I got I finally found a job because I
wasn't during the recession and at that
time when they had me go on welfare they
also had me do these be this one program
where I had to go in at like from 9:00
to 5:00 and they would teach me and I
teach everyone there how to get a job
and like how to do your resume and like
they were there actually trying to help
you to get off it right and I don't
think a lot of people I can't speak for
everybody but for example we were on
food stamps when we first moved here and
I didn't want to be
oh that's welfare okay well we didn't
want to be on food stamps I don't know
why my mom call it a food stamps part of
it yeah well we were on yeah and so so
she didn't want to be so a lot of times
like as Mexicans immigrants we don't
want to be because people already think
that's what we come here for yeah so
when we do get the assistance we're like
I don't ever want to be in that position
cuz I don't want to be like oh see
you're the stereotype like we were right
about you
yeah I never even brought it up like I
think the first time I ever mentioned
that okay so yeah what four at one point
it's not that I'm ashamed of it or
anything it's just that that was just
work hard to get out of it yeah I mean
that was life I heard one of the reasons
why people don't want to get off is
because it's harder for them when they
have to get a job and do all this stuff
like it's on the record note on so like
let's say you're on welfare right and
then so you can stay at home and
actually take care of the kids and all
that stuff but once you do get a job and
it still doesn't pay you're actually in
a worse situation because not only do
you have to go to work you have to pay
for a babysitter that's why they have
all these other programs that I was able
to benefit from which is where they they
pay the government pays your day care
person so I wasn't I didn't have to pay
out of my pocket so they helped me
transition out of welfare exactly oh so
you're saying that all the people that
are on welfare just [ __ ] leave at
least in my neighborhood my block
literally it was generational what do
you mean generations like it was already
three generation
of a family living in an apartment
complex that were like that's just what
we do but they're not straight from
Mexico like they'd been here for three
days yeah they've been here for a minute
isn't fair to offer to welfare yeah they
were like okay the first one that came
here they're like okay I'm gonna stay on
welfare you know what [ __ ] I don't have
to work I don't have to do [ __ ]
maybe I'll slang drugs and get a little
bit more side cash and then they have
kids now those kids are on welfare and
then the kid - the kid it confuses me so
much how they're able to I mean I don't
know now I'm thinking that way but I
don't I didn't understand how they were
able to gain the system because in order
for me to continue to be on welfare
there were so many things I had to do
and so many like checks and balances
that they were making sure I'm
monitoring like that I was trying to do
my best to get a job and that the money
for the daycare went to the daycare and
like and then I had to actually input
hours of how many hours I was doing up
training and like lose a lot of work so
I'm like how these people can be very
experienced and have the loophole wait
because a lot of agents don't ever go to
traffic school because they know of the
Asian traffic so I'll just sign off on
it if you pay them yeah so they probably
maybe a nanny's Chinese so maybe in this
in this system there's people that are
that already know like a certain way of
doing things
yeah and when you're like that and you
have those kind of mentality you'll
[ __ ] figure it
I know but good thing you're not like
that I mean I was on it for a short time
you have a brand-new ps2 back then but
she never would have had a Tesla that's
cheap you know that's dope
[Music]
[Music]